welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka re-captain america
and this video we're breaking down what
if episode two the new marvel show is
filled with the brim with easter eggs
hidden details and things you missed
that we'll be dissecting throughout this
video the episode itself asks the
question what if t'challa was picked up
by yondu and it features one of the
final performances by chadwick boseman
bozeman of course sadly passed away in
2020 and this feels like a fitting
send-off for not only the actor but also
the character that he played it's filled
with positivity and also the message
that one person can make a massive
difference now it has been confirmed
that chadwick will be featuring in 4
what if episodes in total we know that
there's going to be 9 in the season so
he will be back for the majority of
episodes and i'm just really looking
forward to seeing him return now we
start off with the title sequence from
last week which we broke down in our
last video just in case you want to see
what's going on with it however we get
an added section with the watcher
talking about how space itself is filled
with the multiverse where we see lights
he sees worlds and this idea of all the
universes existing at once was actually
shown at the start of loki episode 6
when we pulled out of our universe and
traveled into a parallel one often when
the multiverse is depicted in comics
it's literally worlds alongside each
other so i love how there's this idea
that you can travel to a parallel
dimension if you journey far enough the
watcher ponders whether your destiny is
determined by your nature or if your
nature is determined by your destiny the
entry does wrestle back and forth
between this question but it shows how
t'challa's kindness has changed the
universe for the better now this episode
heavily pulls from guardians of the
galaxy vol 1 and whereas that movie
opened on earth 1988 here we pick up
immediately a morag putting the scene
from guardians and this one side by side
we can see that the coordinates are
exactly the same with the planet's
placement starting with a j and then a
long list of numbers that that probably
ends in 69 now i was hoping it was gonna
be one number off to show that it was a
parallel morag but no just waste kevin
spoilers time comparing screenshots for
nothing now there are hints early on
that this isn't star-lord and the eyes
on the character's helmet are purple
rather than red his jacket is also dark
purple and gold which are of course
colors associated with t'chola and the
black panther when t'challa reveals his
face we can also see that the jacket has
markings on it which are similar the
necklaces that the black panther suit
comes out of both he and peter quill
pull the power stone orb out through the
use of a magnet and as we learned in the
first avenger it's dangerous for people
to touch an infinity stone with their
bare hands at the end of the avengers
bruce banner used prongs and even in
infinity war when strange handed over
the time stone he used his powers to
pass it over rather than holding it
directly just like guardians star-lord
is confronted by korath but rather than
having no clue who peter quill is he's a
massive fan of t'challa we learn that
t'challa is a robin hood figure that
takes power from the powerful and gives
it to the powerless korath kneels before
him and t'challa says that isn't
necessary which is a nod to infinity war
in which bruce banner went to bow and he
said we don't do that here korath is
completely enamored by him and he says
that he's a lord which t'challa says
isn't an official title this completely
jokes to poses how people were with
starlord and they made fun of his
nickname and didn't take him seriously
it even got to the point that when he
was taken prisoner by the zandarians
that they listed his name as space lord
instead of the real one say kids you get
all the good details here like that now
korra wants to fight star-lord so that
he can brag about facing off against him
and though the former easily bests him
it's hilarious how korath gets knocked
out with a smile on his face to charlie
uses the magnets to propel the soldiers
against the wall and this is very
similar to the kinetic blasts that he
had in his black panther suit
interestingly quill completely
disintegrated them whereas t'challa just
knocks them out showing the difference
between the two as the ladder is
non-lethal he travels outside where he
comes face to face with several soldiers
and he says a ravager never flies solo
to which yondu arrives in guardians
quill of course went off from the
ravages to do this mission by himself
and he was against yondu for the
majority of the movie he only says in
the old days they would have sold it to
the highest bidder and in guardians
quill of course went to that dude with
the funny the funny eyebrows with his
shop i went there once and i browsed to
myself eh so uh puns all around now
instead they want to restart a dying
star in order to save the coloring
system it shows that it's not for
personal gain and that they'd rather be
doing things for the benefit of the
universe this is likely why thanos joins
up with starlord as though he was a
genocidal maniac in his head he was a
hero that was doing things in the
universe's best interests now because
peter quill wasn't picked up a lot of
things change thanos ended up working
with t'challa because he made a
difference and thus he didn't team up
with ronin to hunt down the orb korat
still ends up being one of ronan's
underlings but because he's not working
for thanos gamora isn't sent after peter
and thus they never meet now because
t'challa wasn't against yondu he wasn't
on the run and thus rocket and groot
don't try and claim the bounty on his
head i know a lot of you were saying
last week that the captain carter
episode was pretty much just the first
avenger in a peggy carter skin but this
episode really diverts from the original
guardians peter's ship swoops in and we
can see the paint jobs being changed to
purple and gold further reflecting
t'challa's colour scheme that ship was
called the milano namely after alyssa
milano an actress that peter probably
fancied whilst he still lived on earth
bit before my time i was actually more
of a pink power rangers kind of guy but
moving on now the ship was replaced by
the benatar but as neither of these
names mean anything to t'challa he
instead calls it the mandela after
nelson mandela interestingly the mandela
effect deals with the notion of false
memories in which someone recalls
something different to how it actually
happened the condition gained its name
because many people came forward and
said that they remembered nelson mandela
dying in the 80s even though he passed
away in 2013. there have been other
examples of this such as people
believing that shaq was in a movie
called shazam when it was actually kazam
now many have theorized that people with
these so called false memories have
actually moved into alternate dimensions
without knowing it this lends itself to
what if as we are watching alternate
timelines play out in which there are
different outcomes so the name mandela
holds not only meaning because of the
famous south african president that
t'challa might have looked up to but
because of the idea that we are watching
an alternate history play out in which
kevin's spoilers never changed his name
from definition we see the watcher in
the sky gazing over them taking off and
these characters first appeared in the
mcu during guardians of the galaxy vol 2
which links closely to this property
from here we journey to earth wakanda
1988 which slightly changes things up to
how peter was introduced in what was
just earth 1988. t'challa is fed up of
living in a bubble which we of course
know from the mcu is what wakanda is
actually located within his father
appears in his black panther suit which
looks exactly like how it did in the
opening of black panther that took place
in 1992 and we don't really see what
happened to kill manga the series
actually looks like it might let us
revisit some characters and this episode
does end with a cliffhanger that could
open some possibilities for the future
we know that captain carter will be
popping up in doctor strange too and the
what if trailer showed her actually
meeting the dock so potentially these
stories could carry on and i'd love to
see what happened with killmonger on the
opposite side of this now one night
t'challa runs into the wild throwing his
spear and upon leaving the bubble he
comes face to face with a ravager ship
we learn that they have been tasked with
getting quill for ego but that yondu
outsourced this to his subordinates
taserface and kraglin who is voiced by
sean gunn jongun is actually james
gunn's brother and he too did the mocap
work for rocket during guardians and the
avengers films
also taser faces
what an idiot this they stay the face of
[ __ ]
now it turns out that they were scouting
for something that wasn't on earth and
the vibranium asteroid is what made them
go to wakanda t'challa isn't freaked out
by the ship because he of course comes
from a technologically advanced society
that probably uploads what-if breakdowns
before the episode even airs hey now
rather than taking him back they decide
to take t'challa with them and it proves
to be the right decision as the galaxy
is living in a time of peace turns out
yondu lied to t'challa and told him that
wakanda was destroyed which is why he
hasn't come back when guardians came out
i know a lot of people couldn't
understand why quill didn't ever go back
to earth but that was the place where
his mother died and it's very rare that
people returned to a place filled with
trauma that gave them the worst day of
their lives unless that place is the
channel heavy spoilers which is doing
what if breakdowns every week now if you
want to stay locked into those
breakdowns then please smash the thumbs
up button so youtube knows to recommend
them to you or you know what just
subscribe and join the crew do both and
i'll i'll give you the superpower to
survive dying the the death of cringe
from the worst dark jokes on the
internet exclusively on this channel
exclusive exclusive exclusive now korath
asked t'challa several questions
including how he managed to stop thanos
from wiping out half of all life in the
universe and we find out that your boy
just gave him a good counter argument
see thought you don't need to chop his
head off you just need to get people to
cancel him on twitter until he admits
he's wrong and apologizes that is plan
was not without its merit and we do hear
him going through the workings of it
later on in the episode now because he
was never hell-bent on wiping out half
of all life in the universe ronan never
killed drax's family whilst he was
working for him instead t'challa
actually helped defend off the korea
invasion a race that ronan is a part of
and apparently drax takes a selfie of
himself and star-lord to send to his
family now i say apparently because i
couldn't actually see drax anywhere in
this episode but according to the
subtitles apparently he was talking in a
scene oh god didn't catch him now that
also giving up his destiny means that he
also didn't invade gamora's planet and
take her as his daughter because he
never pushed gamora and nebula to fight
one another the latter is a normal woman
now with luscious blonde hair instead of
her skin head she still she still talks
like this talks like nebula get a thumbs
up the video and also make sure to
subscribe because
the nebula has had a pretty rough
childhood still though and she warns
tychola not to let her father know that
the orb holds an infinity stone t'challa
rebuffs this by saying he's changed and
that he gardens now which is of course
what he retired to do after completing
the snap in infinity war turns out
nebula has a job for star-lord which
involves getting some cosmic dust known
as the embers of genesis which
terraforms a planet and heals it however
the person that has it is the collector
and from this point out the episode
turns into a heist mission i love how
thanos and nebula refer to their
relationship as being adoptive which is
of course similar to thor and loki who
refused to acknowledge that they were
relatives when things were bad yonu
doesn't want to do it and he brings up
the robin hood code t'challa has but he
calls it robin leech yondu of course
broke the ravager code and guardians by
abducting kids and it was only after his
noble sacrifice that his name was
acknowledged as being one of them the
collector still resides on nowhere but
we learned that he's now working with
the black order who thanos warns are bad
news thanos of course hired them to
carry out his genocidal plan and amongst
these we see corvus glaive cull obsidian
proxima midnight and also ebony moore
who all featured in infinity war and end
game interestingly in the comics the
black order was known as colour obsidian
and colour obsidian was known as black
dwarf which is a little bit of trivia
for you there the collector's slave
karina greets them much like how she did
with the guardians and we see the plan
play out with them posing as sellers
korath and thanos throw a distraction
outside by having a fight and inside
t'challa searches for the embers amongst
the collector's collection now the
collector is completely bulked up like
he's been hitting the captain carter
died and this is probably because he's
now the most powerful person in the
universe amongst his collection we can
see cosmo the space dog from the first
guardians movie and he's also someone
that appeared in the comics cosmo is
based on the real life dog leica which
the soviets sent into space in order to
test what the effects of the journey
would have on the body there's also a
dark l from third the dark world and
these of course could be seen in the
live-action version amongst the
collector's wares and tears we also come
face to face with howard the duck who is
voiced by seth green he gives t'challa
directions that include the frost giants
and also the cronins which is the
species that cork comes from the
directions are too complicated though
and t'challa frees him to which he says
you know what they say you're out of
luck until you've gone duck this was
actually said by the character in
guardians 2 when he was trying to
impress ryan aries mom ho-ho-ho gotcha
you suck her now howard goes into the
bar which we can see is very similar one
that valkyrie was at in ragnarok the
bartender looks pretty much the same i
think this design might have been based
on a celestial but that's still to be
disputed in the comments below
definitely argue about that yeah because
it helps the algorithm and means i get
more views and more money i want to be
rich [ __ ] now the distraction is
discovered and things go into lockdown
which makes t'challa run to the
collector's hangar here we can see the
benatar the grand masters party ship a
xandarian starship and what may be an
x-wing ronan's cruisers which korath
arrived in are seen from the opening of
guardians and also the indestructible
dock ships that appeared in the same
film however the one that makes t'challa
stop is the royal talon fighter which
comes from wakanda he opens it up to
find mannequins wearing the dora melange
gob and they carry a message from his
father who's been searching for him this
entire time now they do a bit of a bait
and switch where it seems like nebula
has double-crossed them but it's
actually all part of the plan it turns
out the collector has a blank spot for
him on his wall but he's disappointed to
learn that he's not a superman who can
fly and shoot lasers out of his eyes
thus he wants him dissected but nebula
arrives and frees the ravages by
shooting corvus glaive through the chest
this sort of mirrors how the character
died in infinity war when he was stabbed
through it and it's sort of like poetry
his jokes getting terrible now it turns
out that she turns out nebula yeah she
wanted to clear her debt with the
collector while stealing the embers
t'challa breaks free from his cage by
using his vibranium necklace and though
ebony moore almost kills him he's shot
in the back by karina not an easter egg
now karina is inspired by t'challa
saying how history doesn't look kindly
on those that lock people in cages and
she decides to join him she was very
much a slave to the collector and in
guardians she ended up unleashing the
power stone in order to escape t'challa
goes to flee and the collector hits him
with a cronin arm which he potentially
got from cork rest in peace corga if
that is cork rest in peace a rolling
stone gathers no moss and i love you now
the collector also brings forth his
weapon collection that includes a dagger
forge from dark matter which belong to
the ruler of the dark elves there's also
captain america shield and magnet which
means that the collector probably beat
the avengers at some point heck he's
even beaten the goddess of death heller
who was the villainess from ragnarok
because her powers were linked to asgard
and the fact that he's got thor's hammer
i actually think that he might have
destroyed the location in this timeline
now the ravages run but thanos gets a
hulk moment and turns around to say he's
not crazy he's mad thanos was of course
referred to as the mad titan and he goes
toe-to-toe with cull obsidian him
blocking the hammer looks a lot like the
moment in infinity war when spider-man
did the same thing in central park he is
however blindsided by proxima midnight
and nebula ends up returning to save her
father from his fate nebula puts some
embers into cole's mouth and this
sprouts forth a giant beanstalk similar
to jack and the beanstalk this
transforms nowhere from a dead head into
a luscious green environment and lets us
know what benefits that the embers will
have now it all seems lost t'challa says
a ravager never flies solo and yondu
arrives to help out together they beat
the collector by freeing all of his
collection and this leaves him in a
similar situation to his brother the
grand master in the post-credit scene of
ragnarok he was of course surrounded by
the people he'd oppressed for years so
it's a nice little nod to that movie in
the talon ship t'challa and yondu escape
and we can see that they also have cosmo
t'challa returns to wakanda and here he
finds his father ramonda and shuri the
ravages sit and enjoy some wakandan
hospitality and craiglin talks about
jump points and how they make your face
scrambly this of course happened in
guardians 2 when he and the crew travel
through hundreds of them at a time
everything seems okay but then we get a
post-credit stinger in which ego himself
goes to see peter quill who we can catch
working at a dairy queen you might
actually recognize this location from
the opening of guardians vol 2 and it's
where ego left his seed
not his seed like peter his seed seed
your dirty bugger anyway the watcher
says that this might spell doom and it's
unlikely that quill would be able to
resist his dad without the guardians at
his side by the looks of it peter has
led a pretty humble life and thus it's
easy to imagine that he would be taken
in by his father who tells him he's an
immortal god we don't know what happens
next but i really hope that the series
picks up this plot point down the road
and we explore the outcomes of what
would happen to peter if he wasn't
picked up by yondu there's also a
possibility that we could see this
universe's gamora as the posters for
what if have shown her wearing thanos's
armor perhaps she continued her father's
mission in his absence and it is
possible that each episode will be
linked in some way i did a big theory
breakdown on this based on the leaked
information we have about the doctor
strange episode and also the fact that
he meets captain carter i can actually
see strange being sort of a nick
fury-esque figure that travels around
recruiting all of the heroes from
alternate universes and this could be
why we see star-lord t'challa in the
trailers during the avengers-esque shot
beside him is gamora in the thanos armor
as well as party thor and what i believe
is killmonger so this cliffhanger may be
picked up down the line and judging by
the hyundai ad we got it may lead to one
big multiversal war also yeah i said
hyundai on the last video and youtube
hasn't let me forget they'll never let
me forget i'm i'm really sorry for
saying hyundai instead of hyundai guys
really sorry apologize you can let it go
now now the episode ends with a fitting
tribute to chadwick boseman and as a
whole i think this entry is a really
great send-off i did get early access to
the first three episodes and not to
downplay what comes next but this was by
far my favorite of the three whereas
last time was pretty much just a
retelling of the first avenger this took
the premise and got really creative with
it and it shows the potential that what
it has there were a lot of people in my
comments last week a bit annoyed that
things didn't change that much outside
of the ending but this really showed the
butterfly effect of how one minor
difference can lead to a universe of
changes i love how thanos and gamora
also changed up too and it's nice to see
the former fighting for the good guys
what do you mean thanos was the good guy
anyway great episode that got me right
in the field and obviously it's a very
bittersweet one due to chadwick's
passing i am excited to see him back in
the series but do you feel that this
will very much be the episode from the
season that he's remembered for and
rightly so it brought with it the
message of doing the best you can to
improve the world and the universe
around you and that speaks volumes to
bozeman's legacy and the kind of man
that he was he will of course be missed
and what a great send off for not only
the actor but also the character of
t'challa as well now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the episode so
make sure you drop them in the comments
section below we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three mcu box sets on the 30th of august
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one on screen right
now say that to you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of episode 1
which will be linked on screen right now
we've also done a big breakdown of
captain america the first avenger so one
of them yeah just whatever you want
whatever you fancy mate it's up to you
if not and you don't click any of those
thank you for sitting with me until the
end of the video i've been paul you've
been the best i'll see you next time
take care peace